[Music]
that's
so stupid you're rocking it obviously
having fun with filters sam and brittany
jetted off to maui yesterday
beaming while getting in some r r and in
spear's first post since her explosive
testimony
the pop star explained she had been
pretending everything was okay because
quote
i was embarrassed to share what happened
to me i just want to be a happy person
that's really important just to spread
joy and be a happy person
that was brittany with et in 2018. now
in light of brit's allegations in court
some wonder if dad jamie made her
pretend everything was okay so he could
continue making money off his daughter's
estimated 60 million dollar fortune
britney spears has paid her father jamie
at least five million dollars since the
conservatorship began in 2008. he really
has grown her fortune you know
by tens of millions of dollars five
million might be a fair
a fair cut jamie's monthly salary
sixteen thousand then there's legal fees
britney pays for her lawyer
and her father's lawyers jamie's
attorney charges more than one
thousand dollars an hour it's probably
millions in total over the 13-year
conservatorship
i'd have actually 102 people right now
as for that 2018 tour when britney
claims she was forced to perform
even while sick jamie spears made over
two million dollars from it
but here's another shocking reveal the
new york times reports jamie recently
sold bridge childhood home to live in a
motorhome parked at a storage facility
in louisiana someone else on the pop
star's payroll
ex kevin fetterline we're told she pays
him nearly 40 thousand dollars a month
in child support
kevin feels that the best thing for
his children is for their mother to be
happy and healthy et spoke exclusively
with k-fed's powerhouse attorney mark
vincent kaplan today
if in fact the conservatorship is
dissolved we'll have to have some
dialogue if that's what is best for her
kevin supports her and being able to do
that as for dad jamie who is quote
sorry to see his daughter suffering
basically his choices are remain
and try to fight and remain as her
conservator
or say you know what i agree with
britney if she doesn't want me
fine but i do think she needs someone
else or thirdly
he might agree that she should not even
have a conservatorship at all
you